[Music]
sure you probably love The Descendants
movies as much as we do and you've
probably noticed how wicked their
outfits are but we bet there's a lot
more to them than meets the eye you
probably won't even believe how long it
took actress Sophia Carson to get into
character first time at the things don't
forget to hit that subscribe button and
give this video a big thumbs up now
let's jump right in to the 10 crucial
things about The Descendants costumes
you never knew the costumes were
designed by Project Runway's Karis on
it's every designers dream to get hired
as a costume designer for one of the
biggest projects of the year but when it
comes to designing the costumes for The
Descendants most of us could agree that
this was a project of the decade German
designer Karis on was a part of the
first season of Project Runway although
she didn't take home the title of the
best fashion designer in America she did
come in second place regardless Sawin
has had hundreds of opportunities in the
fashion world since becoming Project
Runway's first runner up after designing
glorious gowns and outfits for artists
like Queen Latifah Heidi Klum and mary j
blige she was approached by The
Descendants producers and given a job
she couldn't refuse after reading the
script SAW knew that she would never
have the opportunity to design such
glorious costumes again which is why she
never once thought of turning her back
on the project after all it's not every
day that a production needs a boatload
of Punky Gothic clothing items that
mimic the outfits of some of the best
Disney Villains on the market
Carlos's character needed a lot of
costumes there is so much that goes on
behind the scenes of our favorite movies
while it's easy to forget that actors
and costume designers have lives of
their own it can be interesting to
observe them in action from the
sidelines anyone who's watched The
Descendants movies knows that its main
actors go through a long process to get
ready for their scenes however not many
of us have realized that these
villainous teens sometimes put
themselves in danger to nail a shot
luckily for them their well being is too
precious to risk which is white stunt
doubles tend to come into play actor
Cameron Boyce is the man
behind the character Carlos and while he
means business onset he too needs a body
double when he began filming for The
Descendants in 2014
voices character needed a total of five
body doubles throughout the entire film
while this kept him safe from harm it
did put pressure on the movie's
designers after all they needed to
recreate the same outfits twice in order
to make the shots look believable so not
only did The Descendants actors all have
extravagant costumes tailored to size
but their body double also received the
same treatment nearly 2,000 costumes
were used in descendants - after doing
such a fantastic job designing outfits
for the first descendants movie Harrison
was asked to continue her legacy on
descendants to the fashion designer
happily agreed to come on board and
promised to raise the stakes even higher
for the sequel let's just say she didn't
disappoint
since the movies plotline allowed for a
more experimental genre Shaun decided to
watch a great number of Disney movies
and gain inspiration from them designing
the pirate cruise outfits proved to be
challenging
however Shaun and her crew had a lot of
fun with the task despite having a large
budget when it came to costume design
saw never once thought that she'd be
designing over 1500 outfits for the
movies sequel thanks to the movie's
large cast countless doubles in
challenging scenes Shaun had no choice
but to go all-out after all everyone's
outfits had to look OnPoint no matter
what role they had in the film a large
majority of these costumes were created
by hand which added to the challenge
since the movie is a musical and dancing
was required these costumes also needed
to be tweaked to prevent from wrinkling
up or flaring about all in all Shaun had
her work cut out for her tattoos were
added to the Pirates costumes some
people do crazy things to feel like
they're part of a group when it comes to
the pirate crew from The Descendants -
let's just say that they were 100%
responsible for their actions while a
few fake tattoos might have been drawn
on during the movies production the
actors pertaining to the pirate crew
decided to take things a little further
while the Pirates might appear to fear
their leader uma in the
this is far from accurate in real life
as a matter of fact the pirate crew
can't get enough of each other in modern
daylight the crew of young uns took to
social media to boast about their latest
costume additions which just so happened
to be permanent tattoos while the
descendants two designers and never
asked for them to go all the way the
crew took it upon themselves to get
inked in order to stay true to their
role the friends chose to get an anchor
tattooed on themselves well there are
worse tattoos out there we just hope
that they never regret their decision in
the end this tattoo will always remind
them of all the fun they had working
together on the set of descendants - no
wigs were harmed in the making of
Cameron voices costumes at first there
are some movie roles that require a lot
of dedication and by this we mean that
some actors end up having to take their
work home instead of wearing a wig like
the rest of his co-stars Cameron Boyce
was asked to dye his hair in a platinum
blonde shade despite having dark
features and black hair voice agreed to
go platinum blonde for the year and
actually ended up vibing with the look
despite enjoying the outcome there was
nothing that boys hated more than the
process this is because bleaching his
hair could sometimes take a total of six
hours to accomplish after going through
this the first time voice made it a
point to ask for a wig while filming the
second and third descendants movie we
totally understand bleaching his hair a
bunch of times had really affected his
hairs well-being in order to stay true
to his characters look boys ended up
wearing a platinum blonde wig for the
rest of the production and it managed to
for the majority of us boys got a small
taste of what actors like James Marsters
and james michael tyler had to go
through these stars played the roles of
spike and Gunther respectively in the
end these actors had to bleach their
hair for nearly a decade
Karis on gave the villains outfits a 70s
feel to them when it comes to designing
some of the most wicked costumes we've
ever seen Keira song is the one to beat
this fashion designer put so much
thought and effort into her costumes
that her craft almost appears to be
effortless when it is in fact the
opposite of that since the movie's plot
line places every Disney
on a deserted island saw and thought it
would be a good idea to halt their
growth in terms of fashion when you
think about it none of the villains have
had a chance to grow and move along with
the times
which is why saw and thought it'd be
hilarious to pigeonhole their outfits to
the 70s era since the evil teens also
grew up on this island the same type of
feel was attributed to their debut
outfits in order to make the teens look
more rebellious and cool
she chose to add a punk rock look to
their outfits as well this Gorge look
definitely caught the eye of fans all
over the world seriously most of us have
never seen outfits with such style and
personality before dove Cameron had to
wear a wig to get into character a lot
of the actors who appeared in The
Descendants movie had never had a chance
to act before with this in mind many of
them had to learn the ropes and deal
with long production times and
challenging choreography regardless the
movies crew was up and running in no
time
Cameron dove might have been young at
the time but she was no newbie when it
came to singing and dancing on stage the
young American actress landed the role
of mal in 2015 however she'd been acting
in Disney Channel's live in Maddy since
2013 although she would have liked to
dye her hair purple Cameron was
forbidden to do so this is because she
also played the role of Liv and Maddie
who both had blond hair in order to
please both productions Cameron decided
to sport a purple wig while on the set
of descendants and stay true to her
natural hair color while on the set of
Liv and Maddie having to wear a wig
might have made getting into costume a
little more challenging but in the end
everything worked out for the best the
teens outfits were inspired by their
parents colors there's something you
might not have noticed and it's a fun
fact - did you know that designer Karis
on actually designed mal Carlos J and
Evie's outfits to resemble the ones worn
by their parents since creating their
ideal costumes took a lot of time and
planning Shaun decided to take a gander
at their parents outfits and mimic them
to a fault
this gave SAW in the creative freedom
she needed all the while allowing the
audience to know whose child they were
looking at since Mal's mother is the one
and only Maleficent
she chose to dress her up in Deep
Purple's and tight
leather carlos was dressed and spotted
clothing because of his relation to
karela de Ville and Jai's clothing was
made to mimic Jafar's v's look was also
based off her dear mother the Evil Queen
and so on and so forth you get what
we're saying in the end no detail no
matter how small was overlooked by the
descendents fashion team after being
given the opportunity of a lifetime
someone made sure to pour her heart and
soul into her designs and her hard work
paid off the three designs that took
Karis ons breath away during an
interview with Nicole Minaj Karis on was
asked a very simple question but she
still had some trouble answering it and
we don't blame her after being asked
whether or not she had a favorite
costume from the movie the designer
proceeded to tell her interviewer that
she had three of them sawn revealed how
much fun she had designing the villains
children costumes she said this was
especially fun because she got to
rewatch all of the Disney movies while
taking in the interesting outfits worn
by the evil characters Shaun also
revealed that she had a blast designing
mallas coronation gown due to how
glorious and unique it was lastly Shaun
also stated that she was overjoyed by
the fact that she got to design a
Maleficent wardrobe so there you have it
those are three of songs' favorite
descendants outfits with so many
gorgeous designs to choose from it can
be difficult to pick out a favorite
because of this Shaun had to create a
top three unfortunately for you guys we
want to know which outfit rocked your
world the most so why don't you tell us
whose costume you like the best mal J
Carlos or Evie's it took Sofia Carson
two and a half hours to get ready
getting into character isn't something
that happens in the blink of an eye
however it is something that should
happen within a few hours when it came
to Sofia Carson getting into her
character shoes took a total of two and
a half hours every single day well
there's no denying that hair and makeup
can take a long time to perfect it's
also true that female actors have a more
complex routine than their male
counterpart
since Carson's character needed to be
dressed up to the nines
the young actress had to show up about
three hours early to set every single
day but that didn't matter cuz Carson
admits to enjoying every second of her
transformation she said that she used
this time to practice her lines go over
her scenes and relax before a hectic day
of filming began with so many actors and
extras on set it's a wonder that the
team got everyone ready on time if
there's one thing that's for sure it's
that The Descendants fashion crew is
unbeatable are you excited to watch The
Descendants 3 if so let us know what you
liked best about these movies in the
comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
you